detrás del golpe de estado militar y la
brutal represión posterior el ejército
está armado como se conoce localmente a
las fuerzas armadas birmanas bajo el
liderazgo del general
minogue lo llevó a cabo lo que podría
denominarse como un autogolpe parcial
puesto que gozaban de un amplio poder y
una autonomía total durante el mandato
de la líder de puesta al sub si la
constitución birmana otorga al ejército
el control sobre tres ministerios de
seguridad clave y el 25 por ciento de
los escaños en el parlamento pertenecen
a soldados elegidos por el comandante
jefe porque los generales se arriesgan a
desmantelar un sistema construido a su
medida recapitulando en la historia de
mianmar
este es el tercer golpe de
estado-militar tras la independencia de
los colonos británicos en 1948 en 1962
el general ne win dio un golpe e impuso
la vía birmana al socialismo que marcó
el inicio del gobierno de partido único
y el dominio político autoritario del
ejército que se extendió durante 49 años
en 1988 los birmanos se rebelaron contra
el régimen la represión de las fuerzas
de seguridad dejó más de 3.000 muertos
ni win dimitió y dio comienzo la
dictadura de la junta militar
el socialismo y se volvió aún más
represiva liderando mianmar durante casi
seis décadas con la misión histórica de
preservar la unidad de una nación donde
existen decenas de grupos étnicos y más
de una veintena de grupos armados en
2015 los comicios dieron la victoria al
partido de such y la liga nacional para
la democracia quien gobernó tratando de
ganarse la confianza del ejército sushi
y hablaba de reconciliación nacional
mientras negaba las atrocidades de los
militares y no hacía nada para retener
su guerra contra las minorías étnicas el
tan malo uno de los sistemas de poder
más opacos del mundo ha sobrevivido a
más de medio siglo de asedio por las
duras sanciones impuestas por la
comunidad internacional y ahora es más
bien la resistencia del movimiento civil
birmano que continúa saliendo a las
calles de todo el país quien puede
lograr la instauración de un sistema
democrático que pasa por revisar el
indiferente papel de hans and shoots y
para efectuar un cambio significativo en
el mar